sebastian ogier is in his element racing
through the countryside along unpaved
roads and tracks
he is a master in calculating risks in
real time
we do his job because we like the speed
we like the adrenaline we get when we go
fast on such a small narrow road i just
try to push the limit all the time find
the limit but don't don't go over if you
want to win you have to be clever and be
able to
to see when you have to push and also to
see when it's more tricky or more hard
for the car
ochia drives for volkswagen motorsport
the german car maker only returned to
rally in 2011 after two decades away
from the sport
he has already won four races this
season
it's just good to see all the commitment
of everybody and all the motivation that
everyone the support from the brand will
give us the i mean the budget to do it
and we see a lot of process in the
german way of working and
everything has to be really
yeah check checked a lot of time before
that we put it in the race
when olya left citroen at the end of
2011 he took his co-pilot julian
ingrassia with him in terms of
horsepower there's not much difference
between the cars
in formula one it looks like it'd be
different that technology are the
biggest importance and if you don't have
the best car you cannot win so
in raleigh it's a bit more about driving
ogier has a commanding lead in the
championship
if he keeps on winning he's going to
find it hard to shake off the billing as
favorite that he was so keen to avoid